welcome back to cbs this morning a new
york judge is expected to decide today
whether to approve a bankruptcy
settlement from oxycontin maker purdue
pharma now the drug company and members
of the family that own it that's the
sacklers have been blamed by some for
helping fuel this country's opioid
crisis it has been linked to more than
half a million deaths nationwide now
under the settlement the sacklers and
purdue would pay billions of dollars to
states hit hard by opioid addiction anna
werner shows us why some people say this
settlement does not hold the family to
account anna good morning to you they're
making movies about this whole situation
right what a saga good morning the
sackler family of course is worth
approximately 11 billion dollars with a
b
settlement terms would require the
sackler family and purdue pharma to pay
out billions and purdue pharma as we
know it would be dissolved but for some
like tony lagreca who lost his son to
opioid addiction the settlement is
simply not enough
when's the last time you actually like
stood here stood foot on the this is the
first time since he died
wow
it's hard for tony lagreca to visit the
high school baseball field where his son
matthew used to play these were the good
years these are when he was a teenager
a teenager no drugs nothing matthew
lagreca died from an overdose in 2014.
he was 41. lacreca became addicted to
opioids in the 90s when he started
taking oxycontin after a football injury
his father wants sackler family members
to pay far more for selling the drug
that he says led to his son's death the
cyclists i don't think they feel the
pain they need to feel the pain that
these parents feel
i'm just one parent representing
thousands the sacklers own oxycontin
maker purdue pharma some members of the
family are accused by state attorneys
general of intentionally hiding the
addictive nature of the drug in an
attempt to push sales an allegation they
have long denied what you've heard from
the press about the sacklers is almost
certainly wrong and highly distorted
under the proposed bankruptcy settlement
the sacklers would pay
4.325 billion dollars over nine years
settling roughly 3 000 lawsuits
individual payouts to victims and their
families could range from 3 500 to 48
thousand dollars
as part of the deal the sackler family
would be granted immunity from any
opioid related lawsuits 38 states have
agreed to the settlement but ten states
have not
new york attorney general leticia james
supports the deal in a july statement
james said while this deal is not
perfect it gets one of the nation's most
harmful drug dealers out of the opioid
business once and for all
connecticut attorney general william
tong is one of those fighting it as far
as i can tell no sackler will have to
sell a boat or a house or a piece of art
what do you think the other ag's are not
seeing that you're seeing
i think a lot of my colleagues know that
this process was stacked from beginning
they knew that the sacklers were betting
on a broken bankruptcy system that would
allow them to use the bankruptcy of the
company purdue pharma to shield
themselves let's be clear the sacklers
are not bankrupt but legreca says no
amount of money can make it right we
will continue to go back to any place
that the sackler name is on a building
or an art museum or in a laboratory
and put pressure on that company to get
the sackler name off the building and
what is your goal with that
the goal is to just
demonize the sackler family and just
make sure if anybody's last name is
sackler that people across the country
will always remember
what that means and what it stands for
so you come here how many times a week
three or four he visits matthew's grave
every few days on the headstone
matthew's picture and an engraving
showing him walking into a sunrise and i
also
bought three other plots
i'm going to be buried right next to him
so you'll be here with them
that's the plan
while we were at the cemetery lagreca
pointed out other graves to us they were
all matthew's classmates he says who
also died from overdoses members of the
sackler family who were on purdue's
board have resigned in recent years a
sackler family representative denied cbs
news's request for comment at this time
purdue pharma also had no comment but he
told us when we were there that there
were several players from his high
school and a cheerleader all buried in
the cemetery from opioid you hear 4.3
billion dollars and that is a big number
but then 48 000 per family per victim
that's not a big number when you think
about lawsuits and then also what this
doesn't include that's truly priceless
is is an acknowledgement of guilt uh on
the beh on behalf of the sacklers and a
lot of families want that and there's a
lot of rage
they want to hear more they want an
apology and that's why people like tony
legreco he says it's his mission until
the day he dies to go after the sacklers
and i believe that he he will not stop
until he does that i do feel for the
other people whose name is sackler that
had nothing to do with this when he says
i'm going to demonize the name and
sacklers keep insisting they did nothing
wrong but the numbers seem to show
otherwise though
and mr lagreca going to that baseball
field where his son used to play and
just saying
a teenager when he was happy no drugs
that's just absolutely first time he's
been back since his son died yeah
hard to go there and i thank you very
much as always we appreciate it